inflation search to 6.8 in November okay
even more than expected to fastest rate
since 1982 Federal Reserve is expected
to take a very big step towards a rate
hike it's what they're talking about
right now this is a CNBC story uh
they're they're about to announce a
dramatic policy shift Wednesday that
will clear the way and the first
interest hike right next year markets
are anticipating the FED will speed up
the wind down of its Bond buying program
changing the end to march in uh from
June that would free the central bank to
start raising interest rates from zero
and fed officials are expected to
release a new forecast showing two to
three interest rate hikes in 2022 and
another three to four in 2023 the big
wild card for markets is what the FED
says about its balance sheet which was
4.1 trillion dollars in January the 2022
before pandemic was swollen to 8.7
trillion dollars you just mentioned that
there is uh one set of analytics that
said that expecting as many as seven
mini hikes during the year no no I said
that I said Goldman Sachs
isn't that interesting well listen
yesterday was a shock for the markets
and
fed officials are being so aggressive
because they they announced that the the
median probability is now three rate
hikes according to Fed officials
according to the Dot Plot according to
the anonymous votes so a a preponderance
of the the officials on the Federal
Reserve board are now anticipating three
rate hikes next year but as we see Fed
hikes seen starting with yield curve
flattest intergeneration it's a wonky
thing to discuss but the reason stocks
are up is because stocks are like
they're not going to be able to do it
because we we've had the difference
between the two-year treasury yield and
the 10-year treasury yield which is by
the way what I spent all of 2019 talking
about I spent all one whole year talking
about the damn meal curve but we've had
the difference between the two-year and
the 10-year yield go from 161 1.6
percentage points in April at the peak
of the stimulus stimulus checks 3.0 to
where it is today half of that 80 basis
points so it's been cut in half so it's
a record decline once that yield curve
gets really flat it tends to say we're
going into recession so the markets
yesterday were like they can try and
raise interest rates all they want but
they cannot raise interest rates if the
yield curve is flat or even worse
inverted because that signals a
recession so try me go for it hurry up
with the taper right now they're on
track because they've doubled the size
of their the reduction in purchases to
from 15 to 30 billion dollars starting
in January so they're on track to finish
with the taper to stop growing balance
sheet by March 15th at the rate that
they have announced officially yesterday
so in theory on the March 17th meeting
two meetings from now they could launch
the first interest rate hike but let's
go back to tax season and the money that
people are not getting back in interest
in income tax refunds and the child tax
credit not being paid January the 15th
for the first time and Biden seeming to
pull it out of his the February the
first student loan repayment let's talk
about what the first quarter of this
economy is going to look like and
whether the fed's going to be able to do
a single interest rate despite inflation
which if there's a word for it it's
called stagflation and it's the worst of
all possible situations because your
growth is slowing while prices are still
Rising it's the hardest to break and it
is the hardest to break and wait till
people start getting their energy bills
over the winter
it gets cold forget it game over you
know when it comes to the Biden
Administration it's going to be praying
for covid strain number six to distract
the American people from the fact that
a multi-point assault on the economy is
happening how bad do you think it's
going to be how bad do you think JP
Morgan came out yesterday morning and
they said you know what our health care
conference is going virtual
so let's try and multiply that out right
when travel's coming back right when
right right when all the everything
in-person conferences I mean I've got
them lined up that's one of the biggest
of the Year probably that's in San
Francisco I believe it is now virtual
could you imagine if people had access
to these types of conversations a year
ago right before the election do you
think it would have changed people's
minds knowing where the economy was
going because a lot of people predicted
this this isn't something executive
order the USDA into increasing the food
stamp program by 32 this is I mean this
is like what's being done to the U.S
taxpayer quietly is is just criminal and
you just need more people to talk about
it and I'm telling you 61 seats a
61-seat swing come November is going to
look like a walk in the park welcome to
what's going to happen the narrative's
already shifted you can tell and it's a
story later if we want to talk about it
but even how some of these liberal
Mayors are talking about crime right now
they're actually admitting that it
exists and you know that's a preemptive
strike for the elections but when it
comes to inflation I think sure
everybody has this that's true aha
moment right when you realize inflation
is real for me it hit me the other day I
was at the grocery store I bought two
apples I was going to buy two apples two
apples it was like four bucks for 450
I'm going for for two apples what's
what's in the Apple well Jackson had
hidden some marijuana in there that's
what I'm saying
I had to throw it over the wall
ET it's the secret special that was a
bad apple no wonder you're in a good
mood it makes sense how about them
apples
these apples I like them apples but
David is in Fuego this morning but you
know I don't need those apples that bad
I don't need apples right that's a
ridiculous four or five pounds I didn't
buy this dude for two apples I didn't
buy the pound of bacon somebody told me
it was 10 bucks for a bag of oranges you
have a problem with bacon this guy's got
a problem with apples so if you enjoy
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
oh